there is a giant mosque being planned to
be built in an area right adjacent to
Ground
Zero um and um for example and then and
who had the story I guess it was
worldnet daily and Andrea piser writing
about it New York Post today but Human
Rights group is calling on Americans
especially family and friends and loved
ones who were
lost uh when terrorists murdered nearly
3,000 people on September 11th to fight
the construction of this 13 story
Islamic mosque right steps away from
ground
zero and the group called
stop uh well basically it say Atlas
shrugs uh pamer Geller blogger and
columnist is hosting an a no 911 mosque
rally at Ground Zero on June 6 to
protest the
construction and uh she now joins us on
our newsmaker line she's the editor of
this and executive of the freedom
Defense Initiative and also with us
uh Michael ghost uh who was the
foundation of pluralism and World Muslim
Congress guys welcome to the program
thanks for having me Sean all right
Pamela why don't you tell
us Pamela tell us what your effort is
involved with here well we are uh
calling Americans from across the
country and they're coming and also we
have people coming transatlantically
from Europe to stand at Ground Zero on
June the 6th the anniversary of D-Day uh
to protest this me a mosque on sacred
ground uh we feel what could be more
insulting and humiliating than a monster
mosque in the shadow of the World Trade
Center buildings that were brought down
by an Islamic Jihad attack um any decent
American any Muslim or or otherwise
wouldn't dream of such an insult it's a
stab in the in the heart in the soul of
America and we chose D-Day because
that's when Americans acted against the
evil of Nazism and it's time for
Americans to stand up against the evil
of um Islamic Jihadi terrorism and
Islamic supremacism
Michael well first of all P I believe
your website said it is Islam inspired
nacism do you believe in that Pamela I
believe in the last books of the Quran
the book of Medina there is prescribed
violence for Jihad um it's not my
independent belief I mean since 9/11
there have been 15,000 Islamic attacks
across the world just last week you had
a Jihadi inspired by the Quran his Quran
was in his room in a holy place he was
training in Pakistan it's part of the
global Jihad this is a reality uh I
think that what would be more in tune
with the American sensibilities if
perhaps there was an Islamic Center
built down at Ground Zero devoted to
expunging the the the Quran and Hadith
of the violent texts of Vatican 2 so to
speak so that we could move forward as
one people pursuing human rights and
women's rights and um moving forward out
of violent Jihad yes well Pamela first
of
all everybody's crying out loud for
Muslims to take the initiative to bring
about a positive change and this Center
cultural center that is being built is
to do precisely that to give voice to
the moderate Muslims so we can subside
the extremist Among Us it is good it
should it should be enaged by every
American that moderate Muslims take
charge and speak up and this Cultural
Center will house one part of the
cultural center is a prior place but
bulk of it is talking about pluralism
coexistence and how to get along
learning about each other that's what
this Cent is going to do it's a very
welcome thing to do and as far as your
comment about well versus in Jihad is
were the m translated verses that you
are couching on for the last eight or
nine centuries look at the Muhammad
Assad translation and 18 other
translations you are going by what was
wrongly translated not rightly
translated Pamela we are all in this my
my advisor are former Muslims Nani
Darwish waa sulan work uh that speak the
language that grew up in Muslim
countries they're the most reliable
Witnesses and I find the naming of it
the Cordoba uh or Cordoba initiative uh
where it's being painted as sort of a
multicultural tolerant period when in
fact it was not when in fact non-muslims
Christians and Jews were forced to live
under dimude subclass status they had to
pay a special tax the gizia and this the
message of cord I find very troubling in
addition wait and I will I will speak I
will let you speak the expression of
conquest and supremacism has been made
painfully clear in building a 13-story
mega mosque on the sacred grounds of
groundzero how insensitive Mike I ask
you where if a stick figure is drawn and
the name of the stick figure is Muhammad
buildings are set of fire people are
killed the Danish cartoons because we're
not being sensitive to the fact that
that would be found slanderous because
slander in Islam is completely different
than slander in the west but to install
a 13t mosque where the teachings of
jihad are taught that bring those
buildings down and bring down the
Pentagon and bring was going to bring
down the Capitol Building these are all
icons that was the financial icon the
Pentagon was the military icon for this
power most powerful army in the world uh
the White House or capital building was
the epicenter of power in the world and
just last week the bomb was for Time
Square which is the icon of
entertainment in the Western World now I
wish these things were not happening
they grieve me enormously but we are in
America and why do we have to islamicize
America why can't America americanize
Islam first of all I think you're
cooking up the things about going to
teach you I don't know where you got
that from you don't have any information
that they're going to teach about
pluralism and coexistence not what your
version of this story I'm glad you are
giving one point because it keeps us all
of us alert we should not tolerate any
teachings of jihad anywhere in the world
not only in America Muslims stand up
against that kind of teaching the thing
is we are by doing this Center we are
encouraging moderate Muslims such as
myself to come and speak up have
diversity of thought let different
voices heard let me read from Andrea let
me read from Andrea piso's column she is
quoting uphold protect defend and
celebrate the values enshrined in our
constitution I got your point Prime Min
the prime the Prime Minister of Turkey
said the mosques are our fortresses and
the minettes are our bayonets the
Taliban said to President Obama there is
no such thing as extreme Islam that is
an insult there is only Islam and in
fact what these these devout Muslims are
practicing is pure Islam what you're
describing secular Muslims is quite
frankly in the Quran a punishable by
death that is hypocrisy the word of the
Quran is immutable it is the word of God
delivered to Allah you cannot reform you
cannot reinterpret you are not allowed
now I think that what you're engaging in
here sir is tea and tea in the Quran
says you are to deceive you ought to lie
to advance Islam in non-muslim countries
we we know that isna the Islamic Society
of North America which is an arm of the
Muslim Brotherhood they are Furnishing
all these materials to 80% of the
mosques and who is
funding yes where are they cooking this
up from it is not in Quran you cannot
show it to anybody just because You' got
the mega power your voice is reaching
you cannot lie to the public Pamela I'm
not lying to
this The worlding Scholar the world
leading scholar on Islam I War has
written books I've read them all even
the most silver tongue stealth jihadist
like Tariq Tariq Ramadan speaks you
cannot just be at your way into this
American public American public deserves
to hear the truth not necessarily your
version our version that is what I'm
very glad Shan her is putting you and I
on this show because we need to tell the
truth to the American people yes and I
think the truth I think it's a long time
the truth has become the new hate speech
this is in the
do of the but hang on a second let me
let me let me stop let me let me let me
stop you both Andrea piser writes about
this in the uh in the New York Post
today now by the way this uh this
apparently is this C this this mosque is
scheduled to open on September 11th
2011 uh 10 years excuse me let me finish
10 years to the day that Islamic
terrorist killed 3,000 Americans just
yards away from this new mosque uh and
by the way it apparently will have a
swimming pool uh in a building that was
damaged by the fuselage of this jet
flown by extremists into the World Trade
Center now they she quotes in her
article Paul CPUs who's a member of the
community board one who said a mosque is
a fine idea somewhere else and he's
quoted as saying that if the Japanese
decided to build a cultural center
across from Pearl Harbor that would be
insensitive if if the Germans wanted to
open a center across from alowitz even
after all these years that would be an
insensitive setting I have nothing
against Islam I think why there Pamela I
think it is very insensitive I think
that it is a slap as I said you you see
how upset people get when Comedy Central
actually uses the word Muhammad it has
to be bleeped out which is a form of
self-enforced sharia Islamic law where
you cannot insult Islam and I think it's
why why is it not a two-way street why
can they build mosques anywhere they
would like and yet we can't build any
churches in in in Medina uh and and and
frankly when I say it's an expression of
conquest and superiority I'm not trying
to be controversial I am merely
repeating history all through Islamic
history all all through but but no but
wait all through Islamic history from
the beginning uh Muslims always took
churches and turned them into mosques
all the way back to 5 in Damascus the
umad khif ab Alik took the Church of St
John and had it rebuilt as a mosque took
most of the churches actually in
Damascus we know that they took the
holiest site the Temple mount in
Jerusalem and they put the alaa uh there
and the Dome of the Rock This is not new
this is been going on for 1400 years and
I can't I'm talking to you as one human
being to another I ask you sir uh how
you would feel if you lost a family
member there due to the root texts in
Islam that propelled these men to do
what they did to build a mosque a shrine
to that violent ideology how would you
feel you must somewhere in your heart
understand how painful this is for
people I'm glad you mentioned that yes
for all Muslims every Muslim it's the
painful thing to see some of the
atrocities committed by men who are not
necess
Muslims but they count they they car the
banner of Islam they are ruthless people
in every faith that does not tell about
the faith you got to look the faith for
what the intrinsic value you cannot go
by some idiots out there the problem the
problem is Michael how widespread is
radical Islam how widespread is this
fanatical belief that you know 72
virgins await you in heaven we see one
hang on a second we see we see one
terrorist Act another by people that say
they they are acting on behalf of their
religion the 9/11 commission report says
we're at war with radical islamists
there is an enemy Sean I'm glad you
brought that up in America 1% of the
population is incarcerated the same law
applies to that 1% as applies to the 99%
of genuine Americans you cannot quote
Quran for the abusers has people abuse
American law criminal law you feel
because I have
logic it doesn't work Sean but Pamela
goad but I just want to say but the
Quran is
abrogated it's abreg uh Mike so
everything that comes afterward
supersedes what's before nobody's
cherry-picking no nobody's
cherry-picking I think that's an
important distinction and cab this is a
respected scholar and and it's Islamic
scholarly acceptance that mandates Jihad
and when you say it's just a Fringe I
ask you if it's not Hezbollah or it's
not Hamas it's mil in the Philippines
it's the Pirates the Jihad Pirates off
of I'm running out of time I want to ask
Michael a question Michael do you
acknowledge Hamas as a terrorist
organization Hamas the objectives are
terrorist the idea of wiping out Israel
is dead wrong and that is Terrorism
there is no question about it and is
Hezbollah a terrorist
organization uh I don't know the full
extent of it some of the acts that do
are terrorist acts not all the acts not
all their acts so if so let me ask you
Hitler was good to his dog did that make
him a good man I if they Hitler Adolf
Hitler was good to his dog so does that
he was he was a bad guy he but he was
good but he was yeah but he was good to
his dog he was good to his dog does that
make him a good person does it if they
give lunch if they give lunch at a
hospital and they spend the afternoon
slaughtering people uh what what does
that mean that's complete moral
equivalence well they do some good so so
we're okay with that Hitler was a bad
man are all German people bad people
that's what you're my issue wrong guys
not all people are bad people no wrong
not all Germans were wrong I have no
problem with Muslims I love Muslims I
have a problem with the violent ideology
that is taught in 80% of the mosques
this is my problem the Imam Imam Ralph
who's in charge of this project after
9/11 blamed America blame the Christians
for 911 I I have a problem with that I
problem I've got to I got to let you
both go but I appreciate you both being
with us